[Music]
hi everyone
i'm anushari vasava and i'm going to
show you how you can use
vertex ai to train and serve a
tensorflow model
using code in a custom container we'll
be using a data set
of technical specs of automobiles to
build a model that can predict the fuel
efficiency
of late 1970s and early 1980s cars
you can find this data set on kaggle we
must provide the model with descriptions
of several automobiles from that time
period
the description includes attributes like
cylinders
displacement horsepower and weight we're
working mainly in a notebook
so think of this as an interactive web
tool where you can combine code
computational output text and multimedia
resources in a single home
so we've set up a container in here a
portable environment for working with
our model
don't worry we have all the source code
and instructions for you in a codelab to
try this out at home
so now that everything's set up in here
let's train the job on the platform
i can go here to the trainings tab
create new job
i'll name my demo add a few other
settings like our container url and
compute specs
and now it's off to the races this one
actually takes 10 to 15 minutes to train
so i read a job ahead of time so we can
test it out together
so now that it's trained we deploy an
endpoint and we can now
use this back in our notebook so now for
the moment of truth
let's predict a sample i've added a cell
down here with a sample case
so this is a set of attributes that we
described earlier
but they've been normalized which is why
they don't look exactly like
say a year or the weight of a car i hit
run
and we can see that an automobile with
these values would give us
approximately 16 miles per gallon
so to make this visual i can use a lot
of ready to go
functionality to visualize my data down
here use graphs and charts to share your
findings with your friends
we hope we've inspired you to try
working with your own data
or to recreate this demo check out the
links provided